continúa la información entre las 24 y
hablamos ahora de economía estamos para
eso con daniela blandón es nuestra
periodista experta que nos va a contar
los temas importantes de hoy daniela
porque la ciudad es unidad propone poner
en regla las plataformas digitales de
trabajo liliana buenas noches la
organización internacional del trabajo
advirtió que se debe crear una
regulación para lograr que ese empleo
sea digno según un informe de este
organismo estos trabajadores tienen
condiciones precarias como horarios
prolongados y bajos o de salarios sin
protección social además se estima que a
la mitad de ellos les pagan menos de dos
dólares por hora
hablamos de quienes trabajan en las
redes en línea de conductores como über
o leaf y repartidores o empleados por
cuenta propia que hoy son cinco veces
más que hace una década de estas
aplicaciones el estudio encontró que la
mayoría de empleados de estas
plataformas digitales es menor de 35
años y con alto nivel de estudios en el
caso específico de los conductores y
repartidores trabajan alrededor de 60
horas semanales y apunta a que más del
70% de
dice sufrir algún grado de estrés
asociado justamente al trabajo daniela
pues interesante y en nueva york dejará
de funcionar la cripto moneda por el
supuesto fraude bueno hay una plataforma
llamada bit fin ex la fiscalidad de
nueva york lleva dos años investigando
su respaldo sobre una cripto divisa
llamada tener por supuesto fraude la
fiscalidad de nueva york confirmó que en
2017 hicieron declaraciones falsas al
parecer sobre sus garantías de liquidez
y les hicieron creer a sus clientes
muchos de ellos que adquieren bitcoins
conecta con está escrito divisa que su
dinero estaba protegido pero al parecer
no era así también que llevaban años
comerciando ilegalmente divisas
virtuales y que la una ayuda a la otra
encubrir millonarias pérdidas por más de
850 millones de dólares sin admitir ni
negar su culpabilidad tanto bit phoenix
como usted aprobaron dejar de operar en
el estado y pagar una multa de 18,5
millones de dólares
bueno daniela y américa latina' triplicó
su inseguridad alimentaria severa en
claro que sí esto lo dice la ong acción
sobre el hambre que hizo encuestas a lo
largo de centroamérica y suramérica para
concluir que ese flagelo afectó a 10
millones de personas durante la pandemia
tres veces más que antes de la crisis
cuando eran 3,4 millones en
centroamérica se estima que casi 4
millones de personas tienen hoy
dificultades graves para alimentarse en
perú ocho de cada diez encuestados
habían perdido sus empleos y tres de
cada diez habían reducido sus ingresos y
en otros países como por ejemplo
colombia hay un grave problema de
hacinamiento de liliana bueno y que
propone uno de los hombres más ricos del
mundo para hacerle frente al cambio
climático daniela bueno desde el
multimillonario fundador de microsoft y
filántropo bill gates quien emitió lo
que llamó su manifiesto verde publicado
por el financial times en el incluye
propuestas para que las grandes empresas
contribuyan a mermar las consecuencias
del cambio climático sus propuestas
están dirigidas a gobiernos ongs y
empresas no tanto a personas como no
una de ellas es crear lo que llama green
premium que son como primas ecológicas y
es que estén dispuestos a pagar un poco
más por energías renovables y sacrificar
algo de ganancias se estima que en eeuu
esto encarecería los precios de la
electricidad en un 15% pero hay otras
propuestas más sencillas como por
ejemplo plantar árboles hacer compras a
gran escala de productos amigables con
el medio ambiente e invertir en el
desarrollo de tecnologías limpias
bill gates dice que si lo hace una
persona pues no va a tener mucho impacto
pero si lo va a tener si lo hacen las
grandes corporaciones bueno ni la
contamos cómo están los indicadores de
la jornada wall street' de cerró mixto
se destacó la pérdida de más del 2 por
ciento de tesla en medio de un desplome
del bitcoin que se ha vuelto su divisa
preferida europa también cerró dispar
luego de que se revelara un aumento en
la inflación en la zona euro y en
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
recuperó parte de las pérdidas del lunes
y finalizamos con la cifra al día tres
mil 900 millones de dólares que reservó
la farmacéutica johnson y johnson y en
2020 para hacer frente a las demandas
judiciales sobre su talco para bebés que
ha sido objeto de demandas que dicen que
produciría cierto tiempo de calcio la
empresa tiene múltiples demandas pero no
ha habido un fallo todavía l'aquila
gracias por la información económica y
usted gracias por estar entre las 24
continúen con más de nuestra página web
france24 puntocom nos vemos más adelante
con más información
[Música]